the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today what I want to do is in the within
the lexicon is tell you about nature's
most spectacularly beautiful cofactors
and these are formed from vitamin b12
which you find in your vitamin bottle ok
so what is the structure of vitamin b12
and why do I say there it's
spectacularly beautiful so it's very
hard to see you but if you look at the
structure of this where have you seen a
molecule this complicated with five
membered rings each of which has a
nitrogen in this you've seen this when
you studied hemoglobin and you think
about heme and protoporphyrin 9 if you
look at the biosynthetic pathway of heme
or branch point of that pathway is to
make this ring which is found in
adenosylcobalamin and methylcobalamin
which is what we're going to be focusing
on today and this ring is called the
Koren ring so what I want to do is
introduce you a little bit to this Koren
ring and what's unusual about it
compared to pro tempore for nine that
you've been seen before you've seen
before so the vitamin as in the case of
all vitamins that we've talked about
over the course of the semester is not
the actual cofactor used in the
enzymatic transformation the vitamin
which in this case would have this group
replaced with cyanide is vitamin b12 the
actual cofactors that bind to the enzyme
have that cyanide replaced with either a
methyl group and that's called
methylcobalamin or they have it replaced
with five prime deoxyadenosine and
that's called adenosylcobalamin and so
the rest of the molecule is exactly the
same the
only thing that's distinct is the axial
again so you remember from your
transition metal chemistry you had when
you were freshmen that here you have a
cobalt 3 and it's coordinated to foreign
nitrogen's okay so this would be the
equatorial plane and we're going to draw
it like this
subsequently because you can see how
complicated this molecule is in the
metal sits right and this mitt this
plane but you can see that you don't
have complete saturation of these parol
type rings so there's some pucker and
contrast with hymns which are very flat
and then these are called equatorial
ligands and then you have axial ligands
and so there are a number of things that
again that I wanted to point out that
are unusual about b12 one is the fact
that the Corrin ring again is much more
reduced than a parole ring and so it's
puckered and if you look at the
structure of I mean the visible spectrum
are you use your eye and use your
eyeball method you see that
cyanocobalamin is bright purple if you
replace this our group with a methyl
group
this color turns out to be sort of
yellow orange and if you replace this
with fiber mt.gox adenosine it turns out
to be pink so that's why I say that this
is nature's most spectacular beautiful
cofactor so the other thing is you have
two axial ligands I just introduced you
to these guys on the top face but what
you also see on the bottom face the
bottom axial ligand is this unusual
structure which is called dimethyl
benzene midazolam and it's attached to a
ribose but the unusual thing is in most
nucleus IDEs that you've encountered
like ATP this configuration is in the
beta position it's on the top face of
the sugar in here it's in the Alpha
position so that's distinct and the
other thing that's distinct is the
decorations around the sidechain
compared to what you see in porphyrins
so this is a cofactor we're going to be
talking about and one of the questions
that that you're interested in is where
do we find these cofactors and
metabolism in a mammalian metabolism
they're very the appearance of these
cofactors is quite limited so the only
place you see it in metabolism in
mammalian systems is you see
methylcobalamin ok where this is a
methyl group in formation of the amino
acid Matheny and so the methyl group
from methionine I'll show you briefly at
the very end of this little presentation
comes from this methyl group you use
Dennis O cobalamin in odd chain fatty
acid metabolism so you have fatty acids
that are either either at our odds a
no-brain ones down you get proprio Co
way the proprio Co way through a series
of steps is converted into Melanie Ocoee
which then gets converted to
succinylcholine
in to the TCA cycle and in that pathway
you use an enzyme a mutase that uses
adenosylcobalamin we'll talk briefly
about the chemistry of adenosylcobalamin
also methylcobalamin ok so there were a
few things that i wanted to say about
some generalizations that i wanted to
make about these cofactors and the first
one is that again the Corrin ring is
much more reduced than the parol ring
that you see in protoporphyrin 9 which
you've seen in hemoglobin before the
second thing is that you have this
unusual dimethyl benzyl midazolam in
which you see nowhere else in cofactor
chemistry it's only found in this
particular cofactor the second thing
which I think is the most amazing is
that what you see if you
look back here is that you have if this
is a methyl group or this is this
five-prime deoxyadenosine you have a
carbon cobalt bond well this was
discovered in the 1950s and the first
structure was solved of this molecule by
Dorothy crow for Hodgkin in 1964 and she
won the Nobel Prize did this work no
chemists had ever seen a carbon cobalt
bond and they thought in fact
biochemists were crazy that they even
proposed such a structure so this
structure and we'll see that this this
is where all the chemistry happens is
completely unique and people spent 25
years figuring out how this cofactor it
actually work to do the transformations
that I'll very briefly introduce you to
so this is the first example of a carbon
cobalt and we'll see that cobalt is in
the plus 3 oxidation state bond so it's
the first organo metallic cofactor and
what people also found by studying this
molecule is that the cobalt can actually
exist in 3 oxidation state it can exist
in the Cobell one state we're in the DZ
squared orbital if you don't remember
what a DZ squared orbital is you need to
go back and look at your freshman
chemistry you have two electrons and it
turns out that cobalt 1 is a super
nucleophile and we'll see that that
plays a key role in the chemistry and so
again this is the cobalt the D we're
only looking at one of the orbit
orbitals of the cobalt on the other hand
in adenosine and this is found in methyl
this is going to be used in
methylcobalamin so when you have a
methyl group as the axial again you're
going to use cobalt in this oxidation
state which is the plus 1 state for
almost all other b12 dependent reactions
you have cobalt 2 which has you
lausanne electrons he have one only one
electron by itself in its DZ squared
orbital and this really dictates the
chemistry and so this is found in
adenosylcobalamin chemistry and then in
the resting state you have cobalt 3 and
cobalt 3 has none of the electrons in
the DZ squared orbital and this is
basically the resting state this most
stable state where you find this
cofactor
so in cyano cobalamin which is vitamin
b12 the cobalt is in the plus 3
oxidation state ok so what we're gonna
see very briefly we're not spending much
time on this is the cobalt 1 state it's
a super good nucleophile that affects
the chemistry the cobalt 2 state has one
unpaired electron
you haven't been introduced to chemistry
with one unpaired electron which is
radical chemistry that most people don't
spend a lot of time talking about
adenosylcobalamin because it's radicals
and they don't learn much about radicals
in introductory organic chemistry but
i'll show you briefly how the enzymes
work they use this cobalt to state the
other thing I wanted to mention was that
the colors and so if you try want to
understand how these cofactors work the
different number of electrons govern
what colors you can end up seeing and
again I always use this as an example on
mi t--'s campus in the spring cobalt 2
has spectacular orange color like the
orange azaleas and cobalt 3 is like the
pink azaleas and so they're really
dramatically different this is why I say
this is nature's most beautiful
cofactors okay so what I want to do now
is briefly talk about mechanism and I'm
going to suppose mostly talk about
mechanism of the cobalt 2 state and how
adenosylcobalamin works since that's the
one that's most complicated so what I'm
drawing here is if we look at the
structure
if we look at the structure of
adenosylcobalamin
you see you have a cobalt with four
nitrogens these are the four nitrogen's
and these are the two axial ligands so
this is abbreviated I'm going to be
using in all the subsequent chemical
descriptions of what I'm talking about
okay so I'm not going to draw this
structure I would over and over again
okay so here's our adenosylcobalamin
that we just talked about and there's
DMB is the dimethyl benzyl midazolam and
and then you have the 5-prime
deoxyadenosine and the top face which is
where all the chemistry is going to
happen so the business end of the
molecule is going to be this part of the
molecule and the key to everything is
this carbon cobalt bond now what's
unusual about a carbon cobalt bond it's
very weak if you if you go to 240
degrees the bond breaks most things you
can go to hundreds of degrees and the
bond is stable so it's thermally labile
and then the other thing that's unique
about this cofactor is that it's
light-sensitive so if you put
adenosylcobalamin out on the benchtop
here within two minutes the whole thing
would be destroyed because you would
break this carbon cobalt bond okay and
that's the key to the chemistry of how
this cofactor works okay so I'm gonna
give you a generic mechanism and then
I'm gonna focus on the mechanism of
methyl Melanie okay a mutase which you
find in human metabolism um before I get
started let me just show you what the
reaction is and show you why it's
unusual and then we'll go back to the
actual mechanism okay so what does
methyl Melanie OCO a mutase do again it
plays a central role in odd chain fatty
acid metabolism okay so this is Kawai
you need to go back and look at your
lexicon if you can't remember the
structure of Kawai but just remember
it's a thio Wester that's all you need
to know okay so this is the substrate
and this is called methyl
one'll go away okay so
adenosylcobalamin catalyzes
rearrangements and this reaction has
fascinated chemists for 30 years because
it was a no chemical precedent just like
there was no chemical precedent for
carbon cobalt bonds when biochemists
discovered this there was no precedent
for the reaction I'm going to show you
so what is the reaction it's a
rearrangement and it's rearrangement
because this hydrogen moves from this
carbon to this carbon and this whole
group the SIA West earth moves from this
carbon to this carbon so that's the
actual reaction it's reversible and so
what you do is you generate
succinylcholine is moved over here and
this is succinylcholine and we haven't
talked about it yet but succinylcholine
Tirol metabolism in the TCA cycle okay
so the question that we want to focus on
now is how do you catalyze this weird
rearrangement what is this cofactor this
big huge molecule with this carbon weak
carbon cobalt by not what does it do
okay so I'm going to come back to this
in a minute but this let me show you
what it does okay so this is a generic
mechanism because while I said there's
only one enzyme in humans that uses that
Denis of CO Baumann if you move in to
fungi or you move into our key or
bacteria you find there are many b12
dependent reactions that also do
rearrangements but different kinds of
rearrangements okay so what's the
generic mechanism okay so the generic
mechanism is the following so here we
have our adenosylcobalamin here's our
substrate okay and the idea is and this
is we need to move the hydrogen from
here to here okay
does it just jump through space and the
answer is no the cofactor
adenosylcobalamin is going to
the hydrogen and then it's gonna
transfer it you're going to generate a
reactive species and then it's gonna
transfer it back to form a new product
so the cofactor and this took people a
long time to figure out because it was
no chemical precedent for this is
mediating the hydrogen transfer so
that's what I'm going to show you how
that actually works so here what happens
is the coal key to the chemistry of
adenosylcobalamin which again is is most
of you haven't seen something like this
before because of the you haven't seen
something like this before because
you're not exposed to radical chemistry
is that you have hemolysis of the carbon
cobalt bond so what does that mean it
means one electron goes to the axial
ligand and one electron goes to the
Cobalt so the cobalt 3 is reduced from
cobalt 3 to cobalt 2 and what you're
left with is this radical species of
five prime deoxy adenosyl radical okay
so this is the reactive species because
what you're doing and these in these
transformations is pulling off an
amazingly non acidic hydrogen and normal
amino acid side chains cannot do that
kind of chemistry you have to go to
these reactive radical species to be
able to do this
tough chemistry so here we've generated
a radical species it is sitting right
next to the substrate in the active site
of the enzyme and so what does it do it
removes a hydrogen atom a hydrogen with
one electron okay and so again this is
free radical chemistry that most of you
don't think about that much but what you
do is the hydrogen from the substrate is
now transferred to this axial ligand
that stays stuck in the active site so
we've seen this guy move over here and
now what you've done is transferred one
radical from the cofactor into a second
radical that substrate okay so that's
the key now it's carrying this hydrogen
and
eventually it wants to put the hydrogen
back on to form the product okay that's
part of the rearrangement reaction so
what happens now is and this looks like
magic
I'm just showing that a substrate
radical goes to product radical and I
will show you how this works in the case
of methyl Melanie lock away mute is in a
minute okay so there's some kind of
rearrangement remember we had two things
rearranging the hydrogen but we also had
a second a thioester rearranging so we
have a rearrangement reaction and this
is reversible and in the reaction I'm
going to be talking about today and so
this is the same as this structurally
these are the same I've just written out
the methyl group and so we have a
substrate radical converting into a
product radical okay and now what we
want to do is generate the product and
so the hydrogen from this carrier your
axial again is now going to be
transferred by hydrogen atom transfer
back to P dot to form the product so
again it's one electron chemistry and
doing one electron chemistry the
hydrogen is transferred back to P and
then what do you do you lose one radical
and you generate another radical you
regenerate the radical we started with
the five prime deoxyadenosine radical on
the axial again now I have written here
hydrogen in black and in red why is that
true because here's a methyl group and
if you have free complete freedom of
rotation around that carbon-carbon bond
you can pull off either the methyl
hydrogen's become equivalent so it can
pull off a hydrogen red or a hydrogen
black okay can't distinguish in the
active site of the enzyme so what you
now generate is the same thing we
started with but except we have a
product but we have five prime
deoxyadenosine cobalt do here we have
five prime deoxyadenosine radical cobalt
two and what you do is you reform the
carbon cobalt bond at the end of every
turnover and now you're ready to start
all over again
so that's the reaction this five prime
deoxyadenosine
alig in this axial ligand sitting over
here acts as a hydrogen atom
transferring agent to remove a hydrogen
from the substrate and to transfer it
back to the product okay I'm going to
show you how this works now in the case
of methyl Melanie Alcoa mutase so here's
our methyl Melanie Ocoee and we're going
to be converted into succinate Ocoee so
this again is migrating and this guy is
migrating there that's the goal and so
what happens here is you cleave the
carbon cobalt bond to form cobalt 2 & 5
Prime deoxy adenosyl radical and now
this five prime deoxyadenosine
can remove a hydrogen atom from the
substrate so it leaves you with another
radical this radical goes away you
generate another radical and now this
hydrogen from the substrate is
transferred to our cofactor so it's the
hydrogen transferring agent so now the
question is how does this weird
rearrangement reaction it how does this
co a migrate from one place to another
again there was no chemical precedent
and a literature for this and when the
answer is we still don't know the answer
so there are two mechanistic
possibilities one is that you go through
a three membered ring cyclopropane ring
intermediate so what you can picture
happening is that one of the electrons
from the carbonyl forms a bond with the
unpaired electron on this carbon and you
generate this cyclopropane intermediate
so you've gone from this radical to
another radical we haven't lost any
radicals but now what we want to do is
we want this group to migrate so now
what happens this intermediate can
collapse it can collapse back to form
starting material and the 5-prime
deoxyadenosine radical or you can break
this bond in which case you collapse to
form the direct precursor to the product
so it can break down in either direction
and the reaction is reversible and if it
breaks down in this direction you form a
new router
this radical is distinct from this
radical and now what happens is that the
hydrogen that you removed from your
starting material can be returned back
to the product and what you generate
then is five prime deoxyadenosine
radical and cobalt two and now you've
when you transfer the hydrogen back you
form your product like I showed you in
the previous slide and now you reform
the carbon cobalt bond to form reform
that active form of the cofactor so
alternatively you can make this
rearrangement happen by another
mechanism which is called a
fragmentation mechanism and I won't go
through the details in this but you can
sit and look at this for those of you
are really interested in sophisticated
proposals for the chemical mechanisms of
the rearrangement so adenosylcobalamin
chemistry is unprecedented every step in
the way every step along the way and
it's now known to be widely used but not
so much so in humans but you know really
humans are only a small part of the
world we have many many more bacteria in
our ki then we have humans so this is a
pretty important transformation so
hopefully now when you see this again it
won't be completely magic but this is a
challenging reaction that most of you
haven't been exposed to before but
hopefully some of you get excited about
radical mediated transformations I just
let me close by saying from
bioinformatics studies in the last five
years or so we now know there are over
50,000 reactions that use free radical
chemistry yet we don't talk about
radical chemistry in 507 so hopefully
some of you will get interested enough
in biochemistry to come in and start
figuring out how all these radical
dependent reactions occur not in primary
metabolism but in many secondary
metabolic pathways okay thank you